Dino do i hear joined by Randolph Ramsey
it is the last day of packs in fact the
place is almost weekly the place
happening yeah and there's been so many
games on the show for its it's almost
been impossible to see all of them and
so today the two of us went down and
picked out a couple of games that we
might have been on our list yeah yeah so
we checked out some of the you know
maybe lesser-known titles out there and
today we focus a lot on the iOS / tablet
games and know you had a couple of you
really like yeah yeah I saw some I saw
this really interesting game this game
is called bounden basically two people
hold on either end of an iphone and
there is a screen there's a like a ball
on the screen at you were literally
trying to arcus using like the the
various gadgets until I would know which
way it's pointing yes you're trying to
make this like this pointer go through
the ball so it ends up forcing you both
into like looking at the screen and
doing all this like crazy nonsense and
swaying and stuff and then moving around
in space as well and it's it's free to
cover the guy who made it made this
other iOS game where it was like the
last person to take their hand off
losses so people would pull away like
end up arcing around so he went to a
ballet troupe like Russian ballet group
they like heaven choreograph a weird iOS
ballet game and they did and it was
really good fun but those games sound
like ideal ways to actually drop a phone
yeah yeah big time okay and this is
thankfully because you both have to stay
honest and this was a game that it's
more cooperative but it was really cool
i'm like it was generally fun and me and
drew were standing in the middle of the
hall just just running around like crazy
people tell me one of the games so I saw
this game called Cronin and wolf boy
which is a endless runner / platformer
and I guess the art styles a little bit
of bucket or something like limbo so
it's you know black shadows on a black
background that type of thing it's got a
sweet little story about crow man and
wolf boy which I guess what they sorta
are basically trying to escape this
world of darkness and then you don't
want to get to a world of light so all
of the controls are fairly simple so
it's swipe jumped that top
thing but it's really cool got a really
nice evocative soundtrack and it's
actually out on iOS right now with
Android apparently down the track did
you play it on the tablet i did play on
a tablet i put the headphones on and i
got lost in it for a few min this was
really quite good excellent well so
juicy i know the game that was on a
tablet and it framed framed is great you
played on yeah i had played friend zoe
quinn told us about it on the lobby said
no i had to go down to play it it's
basically a game where you are it's
almost like a comic book of different
frames where this character is moving
through them and then you change the
settings as he's running through the
world basically what you're trying to do
is make sure that he comes out standing
on the left side of the guy with the gun
not the front so he gets shot or like
that he ends up being able to jump over
the chasm by getting on the right yeah
like you're playing around with the gate
with the rules and then playing through
it if it doesn't work you just go up
that's around again a good play again
yeah there's a little bit of trial and
error with it I can but it is quite good
so like in the example that I sort of
played so you're you start this frame
off running from left to right and the
next frame is you know like a hallway
another hallway frame and then like a
table yeah I think okay I should put
that table last because I don't want to
run into it but the way it played out
was a second frame cops cops come out
shoot you in the third frame because
it's just a whole way you get shot yeah
so you actually had to move the table
one in front of that hallway so you
would be able to jump over and use that
as a shield yeah so yeah it's all about
making this like God's be able to run
from you know like run to the whole
perimeter frame without getting shot by
the cops yeah great game hopefully it'll
be ours add the developer said sometime
in the summer time they're hoping but
it's one of these done when it's done
kind of an Aussie developed to oh really
which means it's a hallmark of quality
represent that's right I've had two so
you should have it so the last game I
saw today that I find was really cool
was one called wayward Souls so it's by
either got same guys who made punch
quest which was released on iOS about a
couple of years ago now so this one is a
roguelike so yay another roguelike but
this actually kind of cool six classes
sort of a top-down view and all your
sort of like you know like warrior mage
that type of thing I guess a big thing
with this is you know they've put a lot
of thought into the actual control so
usually in an action game
on you know on on the tablet it's kind
of crappy to be honest but what they
basically done here is you know made
sure that you know basically the entire
left side of the screen can be used as
your joystick so no matter where your
thumb moves it's going to move with you
they'll simplified all of the stuff on
the right side so attacks are just taps
and you know very simple swipes and
slashes that's often a problem with
these games that they become like
handicapped versions of what they would
be on a few answers yeah exactly yeah or
you get that little voyage iPad there
when you sort of have to keep your thumb
in the same place and it doesn't never
quite work so I played you know make
played about 10 minutes of this and it
was you know it worked really well and
it's due out apparently really soon so
end of this month for iOS and a couple
of months away for for android devices
sweet there's four great and mobile
games available that we saw here pack
sees what I like a lot about it is that
oftentimes when we hear about mobile
games it's usually some awful nonsense
that trying to be the next angry birds
or try to be the next big some of the
stuff that we saw here was like
genuinely interesting like it was when
iOS first broke out in the scene where
people were trying new stuff and not a
single flappy bird clones so i don't
know i don't i didn't such that's a
flatty patty yes yes so for more
coverage of pax east and mobile games
stay tuned at gamespot.com